This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. So just Velcro's onto the base of the fan and then we're just turning on the unit. We'll be up in a minute. You see them on street corners at gas stations, at shopping malls. You see them at blowout sales and grand openings of all kinds. They're wacky faces hover over us, and then fall down to meet us, and then rise up again.
这里是99%隐形。我是罗曼·马尔斯。所以它只是用魔术贴粘在风扇底座上，然后我们打开设备。我们一会儿就上去。你在街角、加油站、购物中心都能看到它们。在大减价和各种盛大开业时也能看到它们。它们古怪的脸在我们头顶盘旋，然后落下迎接我们，接着又升起。
Their bodies flop. They flail. They are men. Men made of tubes. Tubes full of air. Producer Sam Greenspan is full of more than hot air. You know these things. A vinyl column perched on top of a fan
它们的身体摇晃。它们挥舞。它们是人。由管道制成的人。充满空气的管道。制作人山姆·格林斯潘充满了比热空气更多的东西。你知道这些东西。一个垂直放置在风扇顶部的乙烯基柱子
with skinny little arms and a big dumb grin, blowing around goofily on a street corner near you. People are familiar with it, but when they're driving by, it's just that you have to look and turn your head. And, you know, four is it's the best return on your advertising dollar you can spend. If by some stretch of the imagination you have never seen one of these things in person, you have probably seen them around the internet or on TV. I am learning some amazing moves from this guy. They are either full of ridiculous, joyful exuberance or the tackiest thing in the world,
有着瘦弱的小胳膊和大大的傻笑，在你附近的街角傻乎乎地吹动着。人们对它很熟悉，但当他们开车路过时，只是需要看一眼并转过头。而且，你知道，第四点是你能花的广告费中回报率最高的。如果你出于某种想象力从来没有亲眼见过这些东西，你可能在互联网上或电视上见过它们。我正在从这个人身上学到一些惊人的动作。它们要么充满了荒谬、快乐的活力，要么是世界上最俗气的东西，
depending on your tastes. A number of cities across the US have actually banned the use of tube guys. In Ordinance and Houston, enacted in 2008, proclaims that the Dancing Tube Guy, quote, contributes to urban visual clutter and blight and inversely affects the aesthetic environment. End quote. I want you to go ahead and try to imagine an origin story for these things. Used car salesman buy some tarp in a leaf blower and messes around in his garage. No. Slided bounce house designer goes rogue determined to show them all. No no no no no.
这取决于你的品味。美国许多城市实际上已经禁止使用气模人。休斯顿在2008年颁布的一项条例宣布，跳舞气模人“引述，造成了城市视觉杂乱和枯萎，并对美学环境产生了反面影响。引述结束。我想请你试着为这些东西想象一个起源故事。二手车销售商买了一些防水布和吹叶机，在车库里捣鼓。不是。滑梯充气屋设计师变节，决心向所有人展示。不不不不不。
The real story behind these is so much better and it all starts with this guy. so much better. And it all starts with this guy. I am Peter Menshaw, born in 1941. The world was at war, so were my parents as a result of which I was taken in my mother's womb to Georgetown, Ghana, where I was born in the general hospital in the embrace of her family and brought back to turn it out shortly thereafter in her arms. Peter Mitchell, ladies and gentlemen, were now in Caribbean artists who could easily have a second career narrating nature documentaries for PBS. I'm an artist, stroke, Mossman.
背后的真实故事要好得多，这一切都从这个人开始。好得多。这一切都从这个人开始。我是彼得·明沙尔，1941年出生。世界正在打仗，我的父母也是，因此我被抱在我母亲的子宫里带到加纳乔治敦，我在那里的综合医院在她的家人的拥抱中出生，不久之后在她的怀抱中被带回特立尼达。女士们先生们，彼得·米歇尔，现在是一位加勒比艺术家，他完全可以有第二职业，为公共广播公司（PBS）解说自然纪录片。我是一位艺术家，兼职莫斯曼。
This is a word indigenous to Trinidad, which is where I'm talking to you from now. In Trinidad and Tobago, a Mossman is someone who works in the Carnival Arts tradition. Peter Mitchell made a name for himself in part by making these larger than life puppets that dance through the street to the beat of a steel drum band. His work was featured in a book called Caribbean Festival Arts, which wound up in front of someone on the steering committee for the Olympics,
这是一个特立尼达的本土词，我现在就是从那里跟你说话。在特立尼达和托巴哥，莫斯曼是指从事狂欢节艺术传统的人。彼得·米歇尔成名的一部分原因是通过制作这些超大型的木偶，随着钢鼓乐队的节拍在街头跳舞。他的作品被收录在一本名为《加勒比节日艺术》的书里，这本书最终摆在了奥运会指导委员会某位成员的面前，
which is how, in 1995, Peter Mitchell found himself in a stadium in Los Angeles, working with a bunch of different artists, trying to figure out ideas for the opening ceremonies at the Atlanta Games, the following year. As Mintle tells it, he was trying to do something using inflatable tubes. But it wasn't working out. It was a total failure.
这就是为什么在1995年，彼得·米歇尔发现自己身处洛杉矶的一个体育场里，与一群不同的艺术家合作，试图为第二年亚特兰大奥运会的开幕式想出点子。正如明特尔所说，他试图用充气管做点什么。但没有成功。这是一次彻底的失败。
But there I am, sitting in the bleachers with a little notepad, and there are all these tubes side by side going up and somewhere out of the haze I just sketched two million flatable tubes and joined them at the waist going into one tube which is a torso and divided them again at the top with arms and a bit of a head you might get an incredible, undulating dancing figure. Boom! The Dancing Tube Guy is born! Mental realized these figures made from a tube hooked on an air source, with dance, just like the people did back home in Trinidad and Tobago.
但我就坐在看台的小记事本上，所有这些管道并排上升，在某种雾霾中，我只是画了两个百万个充气管道，并在腰部将它们连接到一个作为躯干的管道中，并在顶部再次用胳膊和一个头将它们分开，你可能会得到一个令人难以置信的、起伏的跳舞人物。轰！跳舞气模人诞生了！明特尔意识到这些由连接到气源的管道制成的人物会跳舞，就像特立尼达和托巴哥老家的人们一样。
And so, it might, to another person, seem like a great leap of the imagination. To me, it was like jumping into water like a little duckling. Peter Mitchell knew how to make giant figures, but they had always been powered by people, not air. And so while Peter Mitchell was in that moment able to glimpse upon the possibility of giant, undulating, inflatable dancing tube guys, and so while Peterel was in that moment able to glimpse upon the possibility of these tall boys, he knew he needed help. I got a call from the Olympic Games from Peter Minchel,
所以，对另一个人来说，这似乎是一个巨大的想象力飞跃。对我来说，就像小鸭子一样跳进水里。彼得·米歇尔知道如何制作巨大的木偶，但它们总是靠人而不是靠空气驱动。因此，当彼得·米歇尔在那一刻能够瞥见巨大、起伏、充气跳舞气模人的可能性时，因此当彼得·米歇尔在那一刻能够瞥见这些高个子男孩的可能性时，他知道他需要帮助。我接到了奥运会彼得·明切尔的电话，
and he asked me if I can create a human shape. And I told him, yes, it's definitely can be done. This is Doron Gazette, another artist, who, like Peter Mitchell, had gotten known in the Olympics planning scene. He had done some work in the 84 games in Los Angeles. And if there's one guy who knows about making things full of air, it's him. Dorone Gazete first got interested in inflatables when he was a college student visiting the US. Gazete is from Israel.
他问我是否能创造一个人的形状。我告诉他，是的，这绝对可以做到。这是多龙·加齐特，另一位艺术家，像彼得·米歇尔一样，在奥运会规划界崭露头角。他在84年洛杉矶奥运会上做过一些工作。如果说有一个人懂得如何制作充满空气的东西，那就是他。多龙·加齐特第一次对充气玩具感兴趣是在他作为大学生访问美国的时候。加齐特来自以色列。
He saw someone making balloon figures on the street and got obsessed with doing that himself. He sold balloon animals on the streets in Jerusalem, and to this day he still carries balloons around with him in his pockets. And actually I like to say that we don't use the B-word. It's all about inflatables. Gazette founded a company called Air Dimensional Designs, which basically serves to populate the world with his inflatable objects and sculptures. And so after he got the call, Gazette and his team headed over to meet Menshal and see if they could make the Tall Boys a reality, which actually turned out to be a pretty big engineering challenge.
他看到有人在街上做气球造型，并着迷于自己去做这件事。他在耶路撒冷街头卖气球动物，直到今天他依然在口袋里装着气球。实际上我喜欢说我们不用B打头的词。这全是关于充气玩具。加齐特创立了一家名为“空气维度设计”的公司，其基本作用是用他的充气物体和雕塑充斥世界。因此，在接到电话后，加齐特和他的团队前往会见明沙尔，看看他们是否能将高个子男孩变成现实，这实际上证明是一个相当大的工程挑战。
I had to find the right strong powerful motor that will be able to give me enough CFM in the right torque. You get the idea. Engineering physics. Gazete futs around with the materials and the methodologies. And eventually, these tall boys came to life. And they looked very much like the tube guys we see today with two major exceptions. One, they were bipedal, their legs divided at the base, each with its own fan. And two, these things were enormous.
我必须找到合适的强力马达，它能够给我提供足够的立方英尺每分钟（CFM）和适当的扭矩。你懂的。工程物理学。加齐特摆弄材料和方法。最终，这些高个子男孩复活了。它们看起来很像我们今天看到的气模人，有两个主要的例外。第一，它们是双足的，它们的腿在底部裂开，每个腿都有自己的风扇。第二，这些东西是巨大的。
They were 30 or 60 feet high, depending who you ask. And that was the first the world had ever seen of these inflatable men. The 1996 Olympics in Atlanta came in went. And so at this point in the story, the two guys, the tall boys, are out in the world. But how did they go from a thing we saw at the Olympics once, basically as an art piece? How did they go from that to a thing you see at like every used car lot in America? Here is where the Minchel camp and the Gazette camp begin to diverge. By Peter Minchel's account, a few months after he returned home from Atlanta, he got a call from one of his collaborators at the Olympics. He recalls him saying,
根据你问谁，它们有30或60英尺高。这是世界第一次看到这些充气人。1996年亚特兰大奥运会来来去去。所以在故事的这一点上，这两个家伙，高个子男孩，已经在世界上出现了。但是它们是如何从我们在奥运会上看到的一次性艺术品变成你在美国几乎每个二手车停车场都能看到的东西的呢？这里是明切尔阵营和加齐特阵营开始分歧的地方。根据彼得·明切尔的说法，在他从亚特兰大回家几个月后，他接到了奥运会一位合作者的电话。他回忆对方说，
Oh by the way, that fellow in LA who made those things I do believe, in LA who made those things. I do believe you'd sort of better watch your back because I think that he's making them to sell. Later on, Minchelcott win that Jerome Gazete had gotten a patent on the Tallboy, the dancing vertical inflatable. Gazete says that he wanted a patent because he put a lot of research and development
哦，顺便说一句，洛杉矶那个做那些东西的家伙，我相信，在洛杉矶做那些东西的家伙。我深信你最好小心点，因为我认为他正在做这些来卖。后来，明切尔听说杰罗姆·加齐特已经为高个子男孩，即跳舞的垂直充气玩具申请了专利。加齐特说他想要一个专利，因为他投入了大量的研发
into making the tube guys work. And he was already starting to see other people rip off his efforts. The Chinese company just took my designs and was quickly that they could just imitate it and copycat it. Doron Gazit was awarded a patent for apparatus and method for providing inflated, unilating figures in 2001. Gazit reversed them as fly guys. Peter Minchal and Doron Gazit both agree that the dancing inflatable figures were Minchel's idea, and they both agree that Gaseet turned that idea into a reality. Where they disagree is whether or not it was cool for Gaseet to get a patent on it without
来让气模人工作。而且他已经开始看到其他人盗用他的成果。那家中国公司直接拿走了我的设计，并且很快就能模仿和抄袭它。多龙·加齐特于2001年被授予用于提供充气、起伏人物的装置和方法的专利。加齐特将它们改称为飞人。彼得·明切尔和多龙·加齐特都同意跳舞的充气人物是明切尔的主意，他们也都同意加齐特将这个想法变成现实。他们分歧的地方在于加齐特在没有
informing Minchel. He had the vision. He was asking for it. It didn't exist before that, and then a very, very, very much respect Peter Minchia, an amazing other actor and artist, and doing beautiful work. And it was an honor for me to work with him. Gazette says his attorney told him that in the eyes of the law, Minchia would not be considered an inventor. And so Gazette was surprised to learn that Minchal had been angry with him.
通知明切尔的情况下为其申请专利是否酷。他有远见。他在要求它。在此之前它并不存在，然后我非常非常非常尊重彼得·明切尔，一位出色的其他演员和艺术家，并且在做美丽的工作。与他合作是我的荣幸。加齐特说他的律师告诉他，在法律眼中，明切尔不会被视为发明家。因此，加齐特惊讶地得知明切尔一直在生他的气。
He says that since then, he's reached out to Minchal a number of times, but never heard back. Peter Minchal says that it never occurred to him to seek a patent on the tube, guys. I don't, please, I'm an island boy from Krinidad. I don't know if the law is, my instinct tells me that before he could do any such thing, it is his duty to consult with me. Gazette, meanwhile, continues to make money off of the tall boys, fly guys, whatever. He licenses his patent to other companies, like Look Our Way, which sells inflatables here in San Francisco. That's who you heard from earlier. This is Look Our Ways Nick Sanovic. Yeah, so the technology we license from them has to do with the way the air escapes the inflatable.
他说从那以后，他曾多次联系明切尔，但从未得到回复。彼得·明切尔说他从未想过为气模人寻求专利。我不知道，求求你，我是来自特立尼达的岛民。我不知道法律是什么，我的直觉告诉我，在他做任何此类事情之前，他的责任是与我协商。与此同时，加齐特继续通过高个子男孩、飞人等赚钱。他将专利授权给其他公司，比如位于旧金山出售充气玩具的“看我们”公司。这就是你刚才听到的那个人。这是“看我们”公司的尼克·萨诺维奇。是的，所以我们从他们那里获得许可的技术与空气逃离充气玩具的方式有关。
The air escapes both from throughout the top of the head as well as each one of the arms. So that, you know, after testing, that is what gives it its dynamic motion, kind of the special sauce and why it's so effective. Look Our Way has their own name for these things, air dancers. And even though they may be licensing pre-existing technology, they also invented a whole new use for them. It came to them by way of a farmer in eastern Washington state named Gary Long. So little setup. Gary keeps apple orchards on his property, and he started having a really severe bird
空气既从头顶各处逃逸，也从每一个手臂逃逸。这样，你知道的，经过测试，这就是赋予它动态运动的原因，有点像秘方，也是为什么它如此有效的原因。对这些东西，“看我们”公司有他们自己的名字，叫空气舞者。尽管他们可能在授权预先存在的技术，他们也为它们发明了一种全新的用途。这是通过华盛顿州东部的一位名叫加里·朗的农民传给他们的。所以做个小铺垫。加里在他的地产上拥有苹果园，他开始遇到非常严重的鸟类
problem. Starlings were eating tons of his apples, like literally 10 tons a year. Once he's in, he lost 20,000 out of 40,000 pounds of honey crisp apples after they had been pecked out by birds and rendered unsellable. And so Gary Long was looking for ideas. I was talking to a person that was selling his products that he grew on his ranch when in a fruit stamp. And so he wanted to attract people to come to his fruit stamp. So he put one of these air dancers out there that wails and jails and hoping that people would see that the
问题。欧洲椋鸟正在吃掉他的吨级苹果，字面意思是每年10吨。一旦他加入，他在4万磅蜜脆苹果中损失了2万磅，这些苹果被鸟类啄食后变得无法销售。因此加里·朗在寻找点子。我正在跟一个在水果摊上出售他在牧场种植的产品的人说话。因此他想吸引人们来到他的水果摊。所以他在那里放了一个会哭喊和叫喊的空气舞者，希望人们看到
dancers would come over to it and come to his fruit stamp. Well, it didn't bring any people in a very quantity, but the thing that he noticed was the birds didn't bother him. They weren't coming into his fruit stand and pecking on the fruit. Long story short, Gary bought a few air dancers from Look Our Way hoping to keep the birds out. The result? The dancers started dancing, they took off. They went to a neighbor. And so I said, hey, this looks like it's got possibilities.
舞者会走过来并来到他的水果摊。好吧，它没有带来大量的人，但他注意到的是鸟类不打扰他。它们没有飞进他的水果摊去啄水果。长话短说，加里从“看我们”公司买了一些空气舞者，希望能把鸟挡在外面。结果呢？舞者开始跳舞，它们起飞了。它们去了一个邻居那里。所以我说，嘿，这看起来有潜力。
With the air dancers in place, Gary was able to get the bird damage down from 20,000 pounds to, you ready for this, they got bird damage down to zero. Zero damage. Gary long called up Nick Kusanovitch from Look Our Way and made some suggestions for how to turn the air dancer into a bonafide scarecrow. They added bits of reflective material to the head, gave it some angry eyes and some scary teeth, and transformed the thing from an air dancer to an air ranger. The air ranger section of the Look R Way website reads,
有了就位的空气舞者，加里能够将鸟类造成的损失从2万磅降低到，你准备好了吗，他们将鸟类造成的损失降到了零。零损失。加里·朗打电话给“看我们”公司的尼克·库萨诺维奇，并就如何将空气舞者变成名副其实的稻草人提出了一些建议。他们在头上添加了反光材料碎片，赋予它一些生气的眼睛和可怕的牙齿，并将这个东西从空气舞者变成了空气游侠。
Dynamic Unrepeatable Dancing Motion keeps birds away time after time. I mentioned the air rangers to Peter Minchel. It was the first time he had ever heard of them. Well that's brilliant. Next time I open up a packet of cornflakes, I'll smile. Yeah so no bitterness on Minshal's part, even though he's not making any money off of these things. Actually, he loves seeing the two guys around. Could you imagine how I feel when I'm driving down, I don't drive actually, when a friend is driving me down from a house in town to where we are, a factory building place in Shagoramas. And I see a sort of diminutive version of a tall boy dancing up a storm by a gas station.
动态不可重复的跳舞动作一次又一次地把鸟吓跑。我向彼得·明切尔提到了空气游侠。这是他第一次听说它们。那太棒了。下次我打开一包玉米片时，我会微笑的。是的，所以明切尔没有任何怨恨，尽管他没有从这些东西中赚到一分钱。实际上，他喜欢看到这些气模人到处都是。你能想象当我开车时我的感觉吗，我其实不开车，当一个朋友开车送我从镇上的房子到我们在查瓜拉马斯的工厂建筑地方时。我看到加油站旁有一个缩小版的高个子男孩在疯狂地跳舞。
I thought, my God, look at where we reach. And I'm suddenly aware that they're dancing up over gas stations all over the planet. A part of me can't help but feel delight that, you goodness, little fella, look at what you and your Ivan have given to the world. I don't know how much money Daron Gaseet is making off of his tube-guy patent, but whatever it is, you can't really say he didn't earn it. Sure, maybe it was Peter Mitchell's idea, but Gazette actually made this thing. And, as Gazette really wanted me to point out, he's done a lot of other work with inflatable since then. But I also love knowing about Peter Mitchell, and that these things are kind of like shopping plaza ambassadors from the streets of his Caribbean island.
我想，我的天啊，看看我们到达了哪里。我突然意识到它们在地球各地的加油站上空跳舞。我内心的一部分不禁感到高兴，天哪，小家伙，看看你和你的伊凡给世界带来了什么。我不知道达龙·加齐特从他的气模人专利中赚了多少钱，但无论是什么，你真的不能说他没有赚到。当然，也许那是彼得·明切尔的主意，但加齐特确实把这个东西做出来了。而且，正如加齐特非常希望我指出的那样，自那以后他用充气玩具做了很多其他的工作。但我也喜欢了解彼得·明切尔，这些东西有点像来自他加勒比岛屿街头的购物广场大使。
Because that is how he dances. Limpid in mind, the inflatable figures, the tube guys, the tall boys, the fly guys, the air dancers, the air rangers, I've discovered a whole new joy in them. They probably won't convince me to buy a new car, but I will delight in seeing them try. And when I look upon them, I will know to listen for the distant whisper of a calypso band. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Sam Greenspan, with reporting from Sam Dean, who wrote about the tube guys previously, the online magazine Reform, ended by our friend Sarah Rich.
因为那就是他跳舞的方式。在心中，充气人物、气模人、高个子男孩、飞人、空气舞者、空气游侠，我在它们身上发现了全新的乐趣。它们可能不会说服我买一辆新车，但我会很高兴看到它们尝试。当我凝视它们时，我将知道去聆听远处卡ypso乐队的微弱呢喃。99%隐形本周由山姆·格林斯潘制作，山姆·迪恩进行报道，他之前曾在网络杂志《改革》上写过关于气模人的文章，由我们的朋友莎拉·里奇编辑。
The usual crew of Katie Mingle, Avery, Truffle, and Min and me Roman Mars, we helped out, special thanks to Todd Gulick and Barry Standick. We are a project of 91.7 local public radio, KALW and San Francisco, and produced at the offices of Arxan, in architecture and interiors firm in beautiful downtown Oakland, California. You can find the show and hang out with other people who like the show on Facebook. All of the 99 PI producers are on Twitter, so search for 99% of visible and you will find us and you can follow us.
凯蒂·明格尔、艾弗里、特鲁夫尔、明和我罗曼·马尔斯的常规团队，我们提供了帮助，特别感谢托德·古利克和巴里·斯坦迪克。我们是旧金山91.7地方公共广播电台KALW的项目，并在加利福尼亚州美丽的奥克兰市中心的一家建筑和室内设计公司Arxan的办公室制作。你可以在Facebook上找到这个节目并与其他喜欢这个节目的人交往。所有的99PI制作人都活跃在推特上，所以搜索99%隐形，你会找到我们，你可以关注我们。
But you're always welcome at our place at 99pon. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
但随时欢迎你来到我们位于99pon的家。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。